bienvenidos ahora quiero presentarles
una notación diferente para escribir
vectores y resolveremos un problema con
esta nueva anotación y les muestro esto
para que en un futuro ustedes no se
confundan si uso una anotación diferente
de la que ya conocen cuando vimos la
notación de vectores unitarios vimos que
podíamos expresar un vector como una
suma de sus componentes en xy aquí voy a
tener un vector que voy a llamar a y es
igual a 2 por y más 3 por j esta es la
anotación con vectores unitarios o
también notación en general otra forma
de expresar esto es con la natación de
pico paréntesis como le digo yo o
notación de pares ordenados este mismo
vector lo podemos expresar como aquí
está un pico paréntesis este es el
componente en x separado por una coma
del componente en sí y cerramos con otro
pico paréntesis casi como un par
ordenado pero como tenemos estos pico
paréntesis sabemos que es un vector
estos parecen puntas de flecha pero éste
lo dibujaremos exactamente
manera y hacemos esto para resolver un
problema recordamos esto es exactamente
lo mismo solo que escribimos estos pico
paréntesis y separamos los componentes
horizontal y vertical mediante una coma
vamos a dibujar un eje coordenada más o
menos por acá
el eje horizontal el eje vertical y el
problema trata de que tenemos una pelota
que se encuentra a 4 metros por encima
del suelo y la golpeó a 120 metros por
segundo con un ángulo de 30 grados de
manera que esta pelota va a salir
disparada así
con 30 grados con respecto a la
horizontal y hay una barda a 350 metros
de distancia
que tiene una altura de 30 metros
y aquí lo que queremos hacer es
averiguar si esta pelota pasa por encima
de la cerca o golpea contra ella pero
además de esto tenemos que hay un viento
que está soplando hacia la derecha con
una velocidad de 5 metros por segundo
justo cuando estoy golpeando la pelota
básicamente lo que sucede aquí lo que
esto quiere indicar es que la velocidad
de esta pelota se incrementa 5 metros
por segundo a la derecha debido a este
viento ahora resolvemos este problema
usando la nueva notación así que aquí la
posición en cualquier momento del tiempo
es igual a la posición inicial más la
velocidad inicial y recordamos que todos
estos son vectores esto por t más el
vector aceleración por el tiempo al
cuadrado entre 2 cuál es la posición
inicial y ahora vamos a usar nuestra
nueva anotación la posición
inicial
justo cuando estoy golpeando la pelota
va a estar a 0 en x va a estar aquí en
el origen 0 y su componente en ye va a
estar en 4 4 positiva y cuál es la
velocidad inicial bueno su componente en
este de aquí ya que conocemos el ángulo
y la velocidad va a ser igual a 120 por
seno de 30 grados 120 es la magnitud de
este vector y el componente horizontal
va de aquí acá es igual a 120 por el
coseno de 30 grados y este es el
componente en x justo cuando lo estoy
golpeando pero nos están diciendo que
hay un viento que está soplando en esta
misma dirección de dónde va la pelota
con una velocidad de 5 metros por
segundo así que esto
hacer más 5 para tener contemplado este
elemento así que este vector velocidad
inicial va a ser igual y de hecho esta
anotación es mucho mejor porque ocupa
mucho menos espacio y no tenemos estasis
y jotas que nos pueden confundir su
componente horizontal es 120 cocinas de
30 grados más 5 coseno de 30 es raíz de
3 entre 2 120 entre 12 60 60 x raíz
cuadrada de 3 más 5 y esto que va a ser
igual
bueno permítanme hacer el cálculo en
este momento raíz cuadrada de 3 por 65
y esto lo redondeamos a 109 metros por
segundo 108.9 pero vamos a redondear lo
a 109 así que el componente en x de esta
velocidad es de 109 y el componente en
ya es 120 por seno de 30 grados pero el
seno de 30 grados es igual a un medio
120 entre 2 es igual a 60 así que aquí
va a ser 60 metros por segundo algunas
personas escriben estos vectores con
paréntesis pero a mí me gusta indicar
los con los pico paréntesis para
enfatizar que se trata de vectores no de
pares ordenados y el vector posición
realmente es una coordenada pero el
vector velocidad este si no es una
coordenada es diferente y nuestro vector
aceleración va a ser nuestra aceleración
de la gravedad que va directo hacia
abajo y es igual a menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado así que nuestro
vector aceleración
es igual a 0 porque no tiene componente
en x no tiene componente horizontal y su
componente vertical es menos 9.8
si sustituimos esto en la fórmula
nuestro vector posición con respecto al
tiempo
es igual a mi posición inicial que es
esto mi vector posición inicial que es
mi vector inicial que es este
109 60 por el tiempo más mi vector
aceleración por el tiempo al cuadrado
entre 2 que lo expresamos como t
cuadrada entre 2 por mi vector
aceleración que es cero coma menos 9.8
y esa es una forma un poquito más clara
de expresar estos vectores nos ocupa
menos espacio y nos evitamos escribirlas
y las jotas en cada vector vamos a ver
si podemos simplificar esto mi posición
mi vector posición en el tiempo es igual
a 0.4 éste no cambia por el momento más
distribuimos estate en estos dos
elementos de manera que me queda
109 x 3,60 aporte más distribuimos este
té al cuadrado entre 2 aquí cualquier
cosa por 0 es 0 aquí sigue siendo un
0,29 punto 8 entre 2 es igual a menos
4.9 t cuadrada y ahora si podemos sumar
estos vectores mi vector posición con
respecto al tiempo
es igual a voy a poner en diferente
color todo lo que está en el eje x
está a 15 0 más 109 t 0 pues me va a
quedar 109 porte y lo que está en el
componente y esto esto y esto de manera
que tenemos 4 más 60 por t menos 4.9
deporte al cuadrado lo escribimos 4 más
60 por t que se esté menos 4.9 por t al
cuadrado y ya tenemos definido nuestro
vector posición como una función del
tiempo y ahora resolvamos el problema
veamos si nuestra pelota puede superar
esta barra y eso tiene que ver con el
componente horizontal esta componente de
x tiene que ser igual a esta distancia
de 350 por lo que este 109 t debe ser
igual a 350 y para tener el tiempo
tenemos que dividir ambos lados entre
109 me va a quedar que el tiempo es
igual a 350 entre
109 sacamos nuestra calculadora para
hacer esta operación
y 350 entre 109
es igual a 3.2
lo escribimos esto es igual a 3.2
segundos y cuál va a ser la altura en
este tiempo cuando se llegue a los 3.2
segundos pues vamos a sustituir esto en
la componentes de nuestro sector y vamos
a aprovechar esta este como voy a usar t
cuadrada quiere encontrar cuál es el
valor de t cuadrada así que ya que tengo
este resultado acá en la calculadora lo
voy a elevar al cuadrado
y es 10.31 10.3 esto lo escribimos aquí
10.3 y vamos a sustituir esto en esta
parte de acá nos va a quedar 4 más 60
por t que encontremos que es 3.2
24.9 porte al cuadrado y t al cuadrado
es esto 10.3
ahora sacamos de nuevo la calculadora
para hacer todo este cálculo y me va a
quedar que esto 10.3 x 4.9 es igual a 50
puntos 52 menos 50 puntos 52 los
redondeamos a 5 menos 50.5 60 por 3.2
cuánto es 60 por 3.2 es igual a 192 esto
de aquí es igual a 192 más 4 ok ahora va
a ser 192 más 4 son 196 menos 50.5 196
menos 50.5 y me da 145.5 todo esto es
igual a 145.5 esta es la posición en y
esta es la altura que alcanza la pelota
después de 3.2 segundos así que
finalmente nuestro vector posición
en el tiempo 3.2 es igual a nuestro
componente horizontal que es 350
150 como el componente vertical que
acabamos de encontrar es de 140 y 5.5 y
con esta altura definitivamente
superamos esta barra de aquí que medía
30 metros
espero no haberlos confundido demasiado
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo